[Music]
you should have placed your thumb
on there because
[Music]
when you when you come up
you should look like this
[Music]
because this is the band
so if you've got your little finger
caught in here and you're blocking the
band a little bit yes
so we've got now from amonto Nikki
Williams
you go in
on the edge of what press
that again
but if your thing little fingers caught
in here that when you press it blocks
and it stops the little
um
[Music]
so the thing here is to have the thumb
would you imagine that you're saying by
Street Fighters so you press down with
thumb at the same time as you press it
and yeah
that's from a small person should be
able to do the technique as well as a
big castle
[Music]
but if you have the pieces wrong it's
gonna need strength not technique
the Gap needs to be sure
you drive the shoulder into the mat now
from there to each other
[Music]
don't
um
[Music]
foreign